THERE ARE MANY OTHER
DEVELOPMENTS TODAY IN THE
ONGOING IMPEACHMENT SAGA AND FOR
THOSE WE ARE GRATEFUL TO BE
JOINED TONIGHT BY
CATHERINE HERRIDGE, SHE IS FOX'S
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
AND SHE IS WITH US ON THE SET.
>> THIS WITNESS SEEMED TO HAVE A
SIXTH SENSE ABOUT THE JULY 25TH
PHONE CALL BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT TELLING
INVESTIGATORS THAT HE THOUGHT IT
WOULD LEAK IN WASHINGTON'S
HIGHLY POLARIZED ENVIRONMENT AND
ACCORDING TO THIS TESTIMONY
OBTAINED BY FOX NEWS, TIM
MORRISON SAID "I WANT TO BE
CLEAR, I WAS NOT CONCERNED
ANYTHING ILLEGAL WAS DISCUSSED.
HE SAT ON THE NATIONAL SECURITY
COUNCIL AND HAS DIRECT KNOWLEDGE
OF THE CALL AND SIGNIFICANTLY
AFTER ALLEGATIONS THE
WHITE HOUSE TRANSCRIPT WAS
TAMPERED WITH, HE SAID TODAY TO
THE BEST OF MY RECOLLECTION, THE
MEMCOM -- A SHORT FORM FOR
MEMORANDUM OF THE CALL --
ACCURATELY AND REFLECTS THE
SUBSTANCE OF THE CALL.
I ASKED THE NATIONAL SECURITY
COUNCIL LEGAL ADVISOR AND HIS
DEPUTY TO REVIEW IT.
MORRISON SAID HE HAD NO REASON
TO BELIEVE THE UKRAINIANS KNEW
THE AIDE WAS SUSPENDED, AFTER
THE PRESIDENT'S CONVERSATION
WITH PRESIDENT ZELENSKY.
HE HAD REASON TO BELIEVE THE
AIDE WAS TIED TO PUBLIC
STATEMENT FROM UKRAINE REOPENING
THE INVESTIGATION TO THE ENERGY
FARM WERE HUNTER BIDEN SAT ON
THE BOARD.
FOR MORE CONTEXT, THAT WAS JUST
DAY LATER THAT THE AIDE WAS
RELEASED.
A SOURCE FAMILIAR WITH THE
INVESTIGATION, LIEUTENANT
COLONEL WAS WORRIED ABOUT HIS
JUDGMENT AND AT LEAST ONE
OCCASION, HE SAID VINDMAN WENT
OUTSIDE THE CHAIN OF COMMAND ON
UKRAINE.
>> Tucker: AMAZING STORY.
RATHER THAN ASK YOU A
FOLLOW-UP -- I'VE NEVER BEEN A
TV PERSON WHO WAS LESS
INTERESTED IN TALKING ABOUT
HERSELF BUT I SHOULD SAY, THIS
IS THE LAST TIME YOU'RE GOING TO
BE ON OUR SET BECAUSE YOU ARE
MOVING ON TO CBS NEWS WHICH IS
VERY LUCKY TO HAVE YOU AND I
WANT TO SAY OUT LOUD HOW MUCH WE
WILL MISS YOU AND HOW GRATEFUL
WE ARE TO HAVE HAD YOUR
EXPERTISE HERE.
YOU ARE ONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO
OUR VIEWERS TRUST AND I TRUST TO
UNRAVEL WHAT IS HAPPENING
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT IS COMPLEX.
YOU'VE BEEN HERE FOR 23 YEARS
AND I KNOW OUR VIEWERS WATCH
THIS BUT I COULD NOT RESIST, I
KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO HATE THIS
PUTTING UP A CLIP OF ALMOST 20
YEARS AGO, HERE IS A YOUNGER
CATHERINE HERRIDGE WHO LOOKS THE
SAME -- HE OR SHE IS.
>> AT HER FIRST NEWS CONFERENCE
SENATOR ELECT HILLARY CLINTON'S
MESSAGE WAS BIPARTISANSHIP.
>> THE MEDIA GLARE WILL
INTENSIFY WHEN SHE RETURNS TO
WASHINGTON ESPECIALLY SINCE SHE
HAS PLAYED OUT FOR HERSELF.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SHOWCASING THE REPORTING AT
FOX NEWS AND TAKING IT TO A BIG